Lausanne hat ein Drogenproblem
und v.a. ein wachsendes Problem
mit den Dealern.
Aber seit gut einem Jahr
ist in der Stadtregierung
ein neuer Sicherheitschef im Amt.
Dieser hat den Dealern
den Kampf angesagt.
Ein Westschweizer Filmteam
hat daraufhin die Drogenpolizei
2 Monate lang bei der Umsetzung
der neuen Strategie begleitet
und beobachtet,
wie man die Situation in Lausanne
in den Griff bekommen will.
Wie ist es möglich,
dass 150 Afrikaner
offen auf unseren Strassen dealen,
und das seit 3-4 Jahren?
Wie ist das möglich?
Ich verstehe es nicht.
Wir sollten so oft eingreifen und
müssen so viele Fälle bearbeiten.
Wir können unmöglich
alles bewältigen.
Also behandeln wir
die schwersten Fälle zuerst.
Als ich jünger war, dachte ich, wir
könnten in Lausanne etwas bewirken.
Seit einigen Jahren weiss ich,
das geht nicht.
Ich bin in Lausanne geboren.
Wie alle Stadtbewohner
bedaure ich natürlich,
dass die Situation
so schlimm geworden ist.
Auch wenn das nicht
die einzige Erklärung ist,
aber seit dem Jahr 2000
ist der Kokainimport explodiert.
Dadurch hat sich
in den letzten Jahren
der Drogenhandel verdreifacht.
Wir haben aber nicht mehr Poliziste
zur Verfügung,
um den Handel zu unterbinden.
Man kann den Stoff heute
sehr leicht verkaufen,
und die Strafen sind leider
zu gering, um Dealer abzuschrecken.
Das Betäubungsmitteldezernat
der Polizei Lausanne.
Eine streng gesicherte Abteilung.
Hier arbeiten all jene,
die hinter den Dealern her sind.
Sie dürfen nicht erkannt werden
von denen, die sie jagen.
Zuerst observiert eine Equipe
das Geschehen
von einem fixen Standpunkt aus.
Sie beobachtet, wie viele Personen
sich auf und um den Platz aufhalten
und v.a.,
ob mit Drogen gehandelt wird.
Wir beobachten von Wohnungen
und Büros aus, und das sehr diskret
Sind wir im Milieu zu sehr präsent,
spricht sich das schnell herum.
Und wenn wir intervenieren müssen,
ist niemand mehr da.
Für diesen Einsatz wurden alle Kräft
von Stadt und Kanton mobilisiert.
Fahnder und Spezialermittler arbeite
zusammen in der Operation Asterix 3,
dem 3. Grosseinsatz dieser Art
in der Stadt Lausanne.
Die Schwierigkeit ist,
dass wir einen grossen Sektor
abdecken müssen.
Wenn es auf dem Platz losgeht,
werden sich gewisse Afrikaner
Richtung Bahnhof absetzen wollen.
Ihnen müssen wir den Fluchtweg
abschneiden und sie überprüfen.
Alles ist bereit
für die Grossaktion.
Das Ziel: die Dealer
von der Strasse zu vertreiben.
Es geht los Richtung Place Chaudron
im Stadtzentrum -
wichtigster Umschlagplatz
verschiedenster Drogen.
Ich bin mit Kollege Youtze vor Ort.
Ich sehe 3 Afrikaner
auf der Genfer Seite.
Dort gibt es 2 Transaktionen.
Wo genau? Vor dem Bankomaten?
Nein, auf der Höhe
der Strasse Petit Rocher.
Verstanden. Ich sehe den Typen
nicht. Kannst du ihn beschreiben?
Der Afrikaner, der schon 2
Transaktionen durchgeführt hat,
ist schwarz gekleidet und trägt
etwas Grünes auf dem Rücken.
Der mit der grünen Kapuze versteckt
sich hinter dem Ticketautomaten.
Nach einigen Stunden Beobachtung
zieht sich die Schlinge zu.
150 Polizisten - zivil
und in Uniform - halten sich bereit.
In 3 Min.
Gut. Dort rennt einer weg.
Dort ist er.
Welchen meinst du?
Wir packen beide.
Police!
Police! Allez!
Nicht bewegen! So bleiben.
Die 2 auch.
Eine Grossaktion
mit allen Repressionsmitteln,
gut sichtbar für jedermann.
Ist das wirklich ein Schlag
gegen die Dealer
oder wird damit nur Sand in die Auge
der Lausanner Bevölkerung gestreut?
Ich finde es wichtig,
die Bevölkerung zu beruhigen
und Polizeipräsenz zu markieren.
Auch gegenüber den Dealern.
In dieser Phase
wollen wir erreichen,
dass sie sich
ständig bedrängt fühlen.
Wenn wir sie kontrollieren, schicke
wir sie in den Kanton zurück,
in dem sie registriert sind.
Das verunsichert sie.
Sie haben nicht mehr das Gefühl,
tun zu können, was sie wollen.
Das wollen wir erreichen.
Das Resultat:
ein wenig Marihuana, etwas Kokain.
Aber keine grossen Mengen.
52 Kontrollen, 7 Verhaftungen.
Alle kommen anderntags wieder frei.
Es ist gut,
dass wir Präsenz markieren.
So lassen wir diese Typen spüren,
dass es keinen Ort gibt,
wo die Polizei nicht interveniert
und sie unbehelligt lässt.
Denn momentan tun sie,
was sie wollen.
Das Resultat ist zwiespältig.
Ich denke, wenn wir morgen
oder übermorgen wieder aufkreuzen,
treffen wir wieder
die gleichen Afrikaner an.
Besonders an der Operation Asterix
war das, was wir nachher taten.
Auf dem Place Chaudron
waren wir hinterher ständig
mit dem Kastenwagen präsent.
Das zeichnet diese Operation aus.
Wir führten
nicht nur eine Razzia durch,
sondern flankierten sie
mit einer ständigen Polizeipräsenz.
Das hat eine präventive und
sicher auch eine repressive Wirkung
Wir haben eine wichtige soziale
Kontrollfunktion für die Dealer
und die Bevölkerung.
Auch müssen wieder vermehrt
uniformierte Polizisten
auf der Strasse Präsenz markieren.
Diesen Aspekt haben wir vielleicht
in der letzten Zeit
etwas vernachlässigt.
Auch weil uns die Mittel fehlten.
Darauf müssen wir nun
in den nächsten Monaten und Jahren
fokussieren.
Als Lösung für das zentrale Problem
der Unsicherheit und des Gefühls,
dass Verbrechen unbestraft bleiben.
Dies das Credo
des Sicherheitschefs von Lausanne.
Seit 2012 ist er
in der Stadtregierung Lausanne
für diesen Bereich zuständig.
Im Kampf gegen die Kleindealer
haben die Polizisten eine neue Waffe
fiktive Käufe.
Früher waren sie nicht berechtigt,
auf diese Weise Dealer zu überführen
Da die Praxis neu ist, will sich
der Chef der Kriminalpolizei
vor Ort ein eigenes Bild machen.
Der Typ in der blauen Jeans
hat sich vielleicht
in der Seitenstrasse versteckt.
Wo ist der Schwarze,
den wir am Anfang gesehen haben?
Weiter oben, in der Nähe des Parks.
Ich sehe Sebe.
Er kommt zur Kreuzung.
Momentan
ist kein Schwarzer in Sicht.
Weisser Pullover, braune Jacke.
Inspektor Sebe
gibt sich als Süchtigen aus.
Sebe, geh nicht zu weit!
Ich sehe dich noch 10 m.
Jetzt sehe ich dich nicht mehr.
Komm zurück!
Der Schwarze geht auf Sebe zu,
Richtung Kreuzung.
Ein Afrikaner mit schwarzer Jacke,
schwarzer Mütze und heller Jeans.
Voila.
Sie reden miteinander
und gehen Richtung College.
Ein anderer Schwarzer kommt dazu.
Rote Weste und Rastalook,
Kopfhörer und ein Bier in der Hand.
Der Rasta mit roter Weste
nimmt etwas aus der Hosentasche
und gibt es der schwarzen Mütze.
Also müssen wir beide festnehmen.
Jetzt zieht er die Ware hervor.
Er nimmt ein Säckchen
aus der Hosentasche
und wird es gleich Sebe verkaufen.
Geschäft abgeschlossen.
Sie sind bei der Kreuzung.
Ich sehe sie. Geht vorsichtig näher
Ihr habt grünes Licht.
Zugriff!
Gut gespielt.
War nicht einfach mit 2 Leuten.
Auf mit dir!
Auf mit dir! Er hat den Stoff
in die Hosentasche gesteckt.
Bleib so stehen!
Hörst du gute Musik? Verkaufst
einem Polizisten Drogen. Bescheuert
Die beiden Kleindealer
wurden in flagranti geschnappt.
Doch die Gefängnisse sind voll,
die Pendenzen stapeln sich.
Was bringt das?
Hauptziel ist es, die Leute zu
verunsichern, die vom Dealen leben.
Sie wissen nicht mehr,
an wen sie den Stoff verkaufen.
Ist es ein Süchtiger
oder ein Polizist?
Wir destabilisieren das Milieu.
Funktioniert es?
Ja, sehr gut.
Wenn unsere Leute
auf einen Dealer zugehen
und ihm zu verstehen geben,
dass sie Stoff wollen,
gehen sie oft darauf ein.
Fort! Fort!
Erstaunt es Sie nicht zu sehen,
wie einfach man
in Ihrer Stadt Drogen kaufen kann?
Nein, keineswegs.
Das erlebe ich auch.
Wenn ich in Zivil am Sonntagabend
in der Nähe des Bahnhofs
spazieren gehe, weiss ich:
Wenn ich mich gewissen Typen nähere
wollen sie mir was andrehen.
Deshalb war ich nicht erstaunt.
Dealen ist also einfach
in der Schweiz?
Sehr einfach. Und es bringt
viel Geld in kurzer Zeit.
Den Typen habe ich noch nie gesehen
Ich kenne dich nicht.
Sie haben mir Kokain verkauft.
Für 60 Fr.
Gut. Gehen Sie da rein
und dann nach rechts!
Hände aus den Taschen!
Ihre Schuhe, bitte!
Meine Schuhe?
Ja. Wiederholen Sie nicht immer,
was ich sage!
Ich habe gesagt:
Geben Sie mir bitte ihre Schuhe!
Geben Sie mir bitte Ihre Hose!
Meine Hose?
Ja.
Was soll das? Behandelt man
in der Schweiz so die Menschen?
Das ist mein Job.
Ich muss um 6.45 Uhr zurück sein.
Ja.
Ich weiss nicht,
ob er halb betrunken ist,
nicht alles versteht oder debil ist
Jedenfalls ist er ziemlich debil.
Aber nicht gewalttätig.
Nein, aber wirklich debil.
Er will nur in sein Zentrum zurück.
Versteht nicht, was man ihm sagt.
Hat nie was verkauft.
Einfach damit du es weisst
und dich nicht nervst.
Die Beute entspricht
bei Weitem nicht dem Aufwand
der 3-stündigen Drogenjagd.
Eine Kugel Kokain.
Mit der Handynummer bindet
der Dealer den Kunden an sich.
So kann er jederzeit
einen weiteren Deal ausmachen.
Unter der Nummer
ist er immer erreichbar.
Haben Sie Geld für einen Anwalt?
Ich arbeite nicht.
In der Schweiz gibt es keine Arbeit
Meine Frage ist einfach:
Wenn Sie einen Anwalt wollen,
müssen Sie ihn bezahlen.
Gut. Wann kommt er?
Wenn Sie nichts getan haben,
warum wollen Sie einen Anwalt?
Ich verstehe nicht,
warum ich hier bin.
Wenn Sie keine Probleme
mit der Polizei haben wollen,
verkaufen Sie kein Kokain!
Was ist Kokain?
Sie wissen nicht, was Kokain ist?
Kokain ist eine Droge.
Was ist eine Droge?
Das wissen Sie nicht?
Nein, weiss ich nicht.
Warum bin ich hier?
Das wissen Sie genau.
Ich schreibe:
"Momentan will ich keinen Anwalt."
Is it okay?
It's okay.
Ich muss heute Abend
ins Zentrum zurück.
Gehen Sie bitte rein!
Der nervt.
Gehen Sie da rein!
Da können Sie schlafen.
Es dauerte Stunden,
um diesen Kleindealer zu verhaften.
Und morgen wird er wieder frei sein.
Das ist die nie endende
Sisyphosarbeit der Polizei.
Weil in diesem Land die freizügigste
Gesetze Europas herrschen.
In Frankreich,
Italien oder Deutschland
werden Kleindealer viel härter
angefasst als in der Schweiz.
Siehst du links den Schwarzen?
Er verkauft Kokain.
Der Schwarze in der Ecke dort.
Ah, der von gestern
mit der blauen Jeans.
Anderntags sehen die Fahnder
dieselben Dealer
und beginnen wieder bei Null.
Wir versuchen,
sie auf frischer Tat zu ertappen.
Wenn jemand - wie meistens -
Kokain verkauft,
erwischen wir ihn mit einer Kugel.
Das ist weniger als 1 g Kokain.
Wenn wir jemanden verhaften,
der uns nicht bekannt ist,
d.h. nicht vorbestraft,
kommt er schnell wieder frei.
Geh nicht zu weit!
Sie gehen die Rue Valentin runter.
In Anbetracht dieser Sisyphosarbeit,
den stundenlangen Observationen,
um einen Dealer zu schnappen und ihn
am nächsten Tag wieder freizulassen,
fragt man sich, woher die
Drogenfahnder ihre Motivation nehmen
Ich bin immer noch motiviert
für das, was ich tue.
Man muss motiviert bleiben und nich
zu weit in die Zukunft schauen.
Sonst sagt man sich:
Meine Arbeit bringt nichts.
Aber das stimmt nicht.
Unsere Arbeit ist nützlich.
Auch wenn man einen Dealer
2- oder 3-mal schnappen muss.
Wenn er weiterdealt, kommt er
früher oder später hinter Gitter.
Und das Katz-und-Maus-Spiel
beginnt wieder von vorne.
Eine fast rituelle Routine.
Man jagt den Dealer, verhaftet ihn
und lässt ihn wieder frei.
Dieser Mann wurde zum ersten Mal
geschnappt mit einer Kugel Kokain.
Nach 4 Std. ist er wieder frei.
Für Aussenstehende ist es natürlich
schockierend zu sehen,
dass man einen Mann,
der ein- oder 2-mal Drogen verkauft
sofort wieder freilässt.
Aber eines darf man nicht vergessen
und das wird oft übersehen:
Solche Leute
werden schliesslich verurteilt.
Je mehr sie verkaufen,
desto höher fällt die Strafe aus.
Meistens sind es Dealer.
Und meistens werden ihnen
Gefängnisstrafen aufgebrummt,
die sie absitzen müssen,
wenn auch erst einige Wochen oder
Monate nach der Gerichtsverhandlung
Aber sie kommen hinter Gitter.
Grund dafür
ist die neue Strafprozessordnung,
die im Januar 2011
verabschiedet wurde.
Sie vereinheitlicht die Strafprozess
in der Schweiz. Was gut ist.
Schlecht wirkt sich hingegen aus,
dass sie einen Rattenschwanz
von Behördengängen nach sich zieht.
Zum Ärger der Drogenfahnder.
Denn sie sitzen stundenlang im Büro
fest, anstatt vor Ort sein zu können
Und während sie Papierkram erledigen
dealen die Dealer munter weiter.
Au revoir.
Das ist kein Geheimnis.
Seit etwa 2 Jahren haben sich
viele Anwälte darüber ausgelassen.
Die neue Strafprozessordnung
bringt unglaublich viel Bürokratie
und Papierkram mit sich.
Das gab es vorher nicht,
das ist klar.
Wie bereits diskutiert, habe ich
Ihnen vorhin Ihre Rechte vorgelesen
Jetzt wird man Sie vernehmen
wegen Verletzung
des Betäubungsmittelgesetzes.
Verstanden?
Man stellt Ihnen Fragen.
Sie müssen nicht antworten,
wenn Sie nicht wollen.
Wissen Sie,
dass Ihr Asylantrag abgelehnt wurde
Ja.
Wissen Sie, dass Sie
die Schweiz verlassen müssen?
Ja, aber dafür habe ich kein Geld.
Am 13. Oktober
bekamen Sie den Bescheid
und sind trotzdem
in der Schweiz geblieben.
Sie haben bekanntlich einem Poli-
zisten in Zivil Drogen angeboten.
Wenig später haben Sie ihm für
60 Fr. eine Kugel Kokain verkauft.
Sie haben ihm auch
Ihre Handynummer gegeben,
falls er nochmals
Drogen kaufen will. Stimmt das?
Ja, stimmt.
Die neue Strafprozessordnung
sieht auch diese
vereinfachten Verhöre vor.
Dank ihnen können
die Drogenfahnder herausfinden,
wer die Dealer
und wer ihre Kunden sind.
Aber der Richter
befindet über ihre Gefängnisstrafe.
Da die Gerichte überlastet
und die Gefängnisse überfüllt sind,
haben Kleindealer wenig zu befürchte
wegen einer Kugel Kokain.
Das Kokain bekam ich ...
Üblicherweise müssen Sie
für so ein Vergehen hier übernachte
und morgen beim Erkennungsdienst
Ihre Fingerabdrücke hinterlassen.
Dann lässt man Sie vielleicht frei.
Das entscheide aber nicht ich,
das tut der Richter.
2 Dinge verleitet die Richter dazu,
solche Kleindealer freizusprechen.
Erstens
erlaubt ihnen das Gesetz nicht,
so kleine Vergehen
strenger zu bestrafen.
V.a. Verstösse
gegen das Betäubungsmittelgesetz.
Zweites sind die Gerichte überlaste
und die Gefängnisse überfüllt
wie z.B. im Kanton Waadt.
Da ist die Versuchung gross,
solche Leute laufen zu lassen.
Welchen Schluss
muss man daraus ziehen?
Man könnte sagen: Die Polizei
muss aufhören zu arbeiten.
Zu diesem Schluss
darf man natürlich nicht gelangen.
Man muss viel mehr
polizeiliche Massnahmen finden,
die wirksam sind und
den Drogenhandel destabilisieren.
Denn abgesehen
von der Bestrafungsproblematik
ist der Drogenhandel ein Business.
Wenn er weniger attraktiv ist,
hat man einen gewissen Einfluss
auf den Markt und die Organisation
des Drogenhandels in der Stadt.
Die Dealer dealen munter weiter.
Trotz verfeinerter Jagdmethoden
der Polizei
schlüpfen viele
durch die Maschen ihrer Fangnetze.
Nachts ist es noch schlimmer.
Das Paradox:
Die Bevölkerung will, dass
die Polizei schärfer durchgreift.
Tut sie das,
nehmen es ihr jedoch viele übel.
Es gibt Stadtbewohner,
die ziemlich brüskiert reagieren,
wenn sie einen Einsatz von uns
miterleben.
Aber das ist sehr naiv.
Sie sehen, dass sich 2 Personen
am Boden raufen.
Und das steht in brutalem Gegensatz
zur Normalität ihres Lebens.
Aber man muss etwas wissen:
Wenn die Polizei beschliesst,
jemanden festzunehmen und
ihn deshalb auf den Boden zwingt,
tut sie das nicht aus Spass
oder zufällig.
Sie geht viel mehr sehr präzis
und überlegt vor.
Denn die Person
könnte bewaffnet sein.
Man muss verhindern,
dass sie ein Messer
oder eine andere Waffe zückt
und das Ganze eskaliert.
Die Leute wollen unbedingt,
dass die Polizei beliebt ist,
dass alles, was wir tun,
transparent ist
und unsere Weste weisser als weiss.
Kein falsches Wort, nicht
die kleinste unkorrekte Bewegung.
Das alles, damit uns die ganze Welt
schliesslich lieben wird.
Was aber womöglich viele vergessen:
Wenn wir jemanden verhaften,
mag der uns nicht.
Und im Leben ist es nun mal so, das
es Leute gibt, die Delikte begehen.
Die romantische Vorstellung,
dass sich alle lieben,
ist eine Utopie,
die wir nie erleben werden.
Ist diese Katz-und-Maus-Jagd
eine Art Spiel?
Das ist kein Spiel.
Das war es, als ich 10 oder 12 war
und mit meinen Freunden
Räuber und Gendarm spielte.
Meine heutige Arbeit ist kein Spiel
Da geht es um Delikte,
um Verbrechen.
Für mich ist das kein Spiel.
Auffallend ist,
dass fast täglich Nigerianer,
Albaner und Maghrebiner
verhaftet werden.
Besteht da nicht die Gefahr,
als Polizist zum Rassisten zu werden
Es ist nicht einfach
mit all den Afrikanern.
Manchmal ist es schwer,
objektiv zu bleiben
und nicht alle
in den gleichen Topf zu werfen.
Bei der Festnahme eines Dealers geh
es darum, diese Person festzunehmen
unabhängig davon, woher sie kommt.
Das ist mein Fokus.
Ich versuche, meine Arbeit gut
zu machen und neutral zu bleiben.
Ich sage nicht: Alle Afrikaner sind
Dealer. Oder: Immer diese Albaner.
Es gibt nicht nur Albaner oder
Maghrebiner, die Heroin verkaufen.
Obwohl sie die Mehrheit stellen,
darf man nicht so denken.
Das ist nicht gut
für die eigene Gesundheit.
Sonst bekommt man Magenbrennen.
Auch wenn sie es satt haben,
die kleinen Dealer
ständig laufen lassen zu müssen.
Die Drogenfahnder scheinen ihre
Sisyphosarbeit mit Humor zu nehmen.
Was heisst es also,
ein guter Polizist zu sein?
Ich denke,
die Einzahl stimmt hier nicht.
Denn es gibt
viele sehr gute Polizisten.
Als Kopf dieser Equipe
brauche ich wie ein Maler
eine Palette
mit verschiedenen Farben.
Ich brauche verschiedene Charaktere
die sich den Personen anpassen
können, die wir verhören müssen.
Aber der gemeinsame Nenner
dieser guten Polizisten
ist der Glaube an das, was sie tun.
Ich erwarte auch,
dass sie eine gewisse Empathie habe
für andere Menschen,
ohne naiv zu sein.
Das heisst die Fähigkeit, sich
in andere hineinversetzen zu können
Die Fähigkeit zu verstehen, warum
jemand eines Tages etwas tun kann,
das gegen das Gesetz verstösst.
Ein guter Polizist muss das nicht
akzeptieren, aber verstehen können.
Du hast keine Kinder.
Es gibt den sichtbaren Drogenhandel
und die unsichtbare diskrete Welt
der Grossdealer.
Diese zu fangen, ist
den Spezialermittlern vorbehalten.
Ihre Aufgabe:
das Netz der Dealer zu zerschlagen.
Das bedingt oft
monatelange Ermittlungen.
Dank eines Hinweises
können wir ein Telefon abhören,
das einem Kokain-Grossdealer gehört
Wir versuchen herauszufinden, wann
und wie die Ware geliefert wird.
Unverständliches Telefongespräch
Inspektor Sebe
instruiert seine Leute vor Ort.
Ein Grossdealer,
den sie seit Monaten abhören,
erwartet eine grosse Lieferung.
Aus den zuletzt
abgehörten Gesprächen geht hervor,
dass ein Lieferant
heute aus Spanien anreist.
Wir werden eingreifen, sobald
die Ware in Lausanne eintrifft.
Ich habe eine Equipe hier
und eine unten.
Und wir werden ihn hier erwarten.
Etwas im Hintergrund.
Zum Glück ist dort eine Tankstelle.
Da können wir uns versorgen
und müssen nicht verdursten.
Wie lange dauert so was denn?
Wir rechnen mit ...
Nun, keine Ahnung.
Das gehört zum Job.
Wir wissen, wann er beginnt,
aber nicht, wann er zu Ende ist.
Über Funk:  T-Shirt
mit blauer Kapuze. Ein massiger Typ
Verstanden.
Wie es aussieht, ist das nicht Max.
Ich glaube nicht.
Max ist der Übername
für die Zielperson.
8 Polizisten in Zivil warten auf ihn
und kontrollieren das ganze Quartier
Hast du gehört?
Eben wurde bestätigt,
dass der Lieferant heute kommt
und unsern Max kontaktiert,
sobald er eintrifft.
Lohnt sich die lange Warterei?
Sicher lohnt es sich.
In 99 % der Fälle
sind wir erfolgreich.
Wir führen nicht Buch
über die konfiszieren Mengen
in solchen Abhöraktionen.
Im letzten Fall waren es 3 kg.
Aber auch wenn es
nur 500 g Kokain sind.
Diese Typen müssen
für mehrere Jahre ins Gefängnis.
Also zahlt es sich schliesslich aus
6 Std. später warten sie immer noch.
Max muss seinem Lieferanten
in Spanien sagen,
wann er seine Ware bekommen hat.
In diesem Moment wissen wir,
dass er etwas bei sich hat.
Verstanden.
Ich bins. Geht es gut?
Ich bin wieder ...
Ein Fahrzeug bei Fauquet und
das andere im Bereich Vieux Moulin.
Für die Einsatzleute ist alles klar
Es geht gleich los.
Ich weiss nicht, wann ich heimkomme
Esst schon mal! Und ich halte dich
auf dem Laufenden.
Man braucht eine Art Jagdinstinkt.
Den Willen, mit den vorhandenen
Mitteln etwas zu erreichen.
Wir Drogenfahnder konfiszieren Ware
und verhaften Dealer.
Max hat einen Kontaktmann angerufen
und gesagt,
er habe qualitativ gute Ware
erhalten.
Ich habe nicht verstanden.
Wir sollten nicht zu lange warten.
Gut. Gehen wir!
Angst? Ich habe keine Angst.
Was ist Angst?
Angst heisst, dass man
seine Handlungsfähigkeit verliert,
nicht mehr weiss,
was man tun soll, erstarrt.
Nein, ich habe keine Angst.
Ich merke vielleicht,
dass mein Puls ansteigt.
Ich spüre den Adrenalinstoss.
Das passiert fast jedes Mal,
und das erlebt fast jeder Polizist
beim Einsatz.
Police!
Stimmengewirr
Es rotiert wohl in seinem Kopf.
Willst du was sagen?
Das ist nicht lustig.
Die Spannung lässt nach,
und die systematische Durchsuchung
der Wohnung beginnt.
Nach einer genauen Methode,
damit kein potenzielles Versteck
übersehen wird.
Jeder weiss genau, was er zu tun hat
Alles wird auseinandergenommen.
2 volle Staubsauger.
Voller Staub und voller Ware.
Sie ist da drin.
Wir öffnen sie nicht sofort.
Hier drin sind Kugeln
und 10-g-Fingerlinge.
Da drin sind verkaufsbereite Kugeln
und hier Fingerlinge.
Noch mehr Fingerlinge.
Die Beute: mehr als 400 g Kokain
bester Qualität.
Und im Labor wurden Fingerabdrücke
des mutmasslichen Dealers entdeckt.
Nun wird untersucht,
wie rein der Stoff ist.
Davon hängt die Höhe
der Gefängnisstrafe ab.
18 g reines Kokain
gelten als schweres Delikt.
Bei Heroin sind es 12 g.
Zudem gilt es herauszufinden,
woher die Drogen stammen.
Es gibt winzige Partikel,
die bei der Herstellung abfallen.
Diese werden in gewissen Ländern
mehr verwendet als in andern.
Das erlaubt uns,
eine Art Identitätskarte
des Produkts zu erstellen.
Dadurch können wir ermitteln,
wo in der Schweiz
es sonst noch aufgetaucht ist.
Vielleicht wurden
in Fribourg oder St. Gallen
Drogen vom gleichen Typus
sichergestellt.
Dann kann man
Verbindungen herstellen,
z.B. im Bereich der Verteilernetze.
Dank dieser Langzeituntersuchungen
konnte die Lausanner Drogenpolizei
2012 16 Grossistennetze eruieren -
3 mehr als 2011.
Um diese Drogen zu beschlagnahmen,
brauchte es 6 Monate.
Es sind mehr als 3 kg.
Und sie stammen aus Nigeria.
Diese Grossmenge wurde
auf besondere Weise transportiert.
Die eine Art, Drogen zu schmuggeln,
v.a. aus Nigeria,
ist der Transport im Magen.
In diesem Fall hat der Mann
84 solche Fingerlinge verschluckt.
Wie geht so was?
Mit einer grosszügigen Entschädigung
sind gewisse Leute dazu bereit.
Sofern sie physisch
dazu imstande sind.
Denn das Ausscheiden ist mindestens
so schwierig wie das Verschlucken.
Das ist die grösste Kokainbeute
in der Karriere von Inspektor Sebe.
In der Schweiz werden jährlich
4-5 t Kokain konsumiert.
Die Polizei beschlagnahmt
höchstens 10 % davon.
Vor einigen Jahren
hatten wir den Eindruck,
Beschlagnahmungen
würden mehr Wirkung zeigen.
In den Folgetagen gab es
weniger Stoff auf der Strasse.
Heute ist das nicht mehr der Fall.
Es gelangt zu viel Kokain
in die Schweiz.
Es gibt zu viele Grossisten
und Kleindealer.
Wir können kaum noch etwas bewirken
Auch nach einer Beschlagnahmung
rennen die Abhängigen
hinter den Dealern her.
Wir haben irgendwie resigniert.
Wir denken zwar nicht ständig,
dass wir den Genfersee
mit dem Löffel ausschöpfen.
Aber wir wissen, dass unsere Arbeit
ziemlich nutzlos ist.
Wir können den Drogenverkehr
nicht unterbinden.
Wir können einzig schauen,
dass das Ganze nicht vollständig
aus dem Ruder läuft.
Ich weiss nicht, ob du den Süchtige
vor der Kirche siehst,
den Schwarzen mit der Kapuze.
Laut Ben ist da noch
ein Typ mit grauer Mütze.
Die sind zugedröhnt.
Wie auf einem Suq.
Der mit der schwarzen Mütze
ist total zu.
Während der Kokainhandel explodiert,
taucht auch ein altbekanntes Produkt
wieder auf: Heroin.
Seit dem Arabischen Frühling
sind neue Dealer auf dem Markt.
Die Fahnder
observieren die Drogenabhängigen.
Denn die Dealer
sind meistens nicht weit weg.
Oft arbeiten Drogenabhängige,
meistens Frauen, für die Araber.
V.a. die nordafrikanischen Dealer
profitieren davon.
Die Süchtigen verkaufen Stoff für
sie, und die Dealer kassieren ab.
Die Abhängigen
bekommen so ihre Dosis.
Oft werden die Süchtigen
zum Dealen gezwungen.
Wir haben einige Aussagen von
Konsumenten, die gezwungen wurden,
Drogen zu verkaufen -
oft für die Nordafrikaner.
Da die abhängigen Frauen
verletzlicher sind,
versuchen die Polizisten,
Vergewaltigungen zu verhindern.
1 Std. später
wird eine Drogenabhängige verhaftet
und auf der Polizeistation verhört.
Um 23.40 Uhr wurden Sie
nach mehreren Kontakten
mit Abhängigen und Arabern
auf dem Place de la Ripone
mit 6 Päckchen Heroin erwischt.
Was sagen Sie dazu?
Wann kamen Sie auf den Platz?
Um 22.15 oder 22.30 Uhr.
Dann habe ich gewartet,
bis 3 Personen auf mich zukamen
und fragten, ob ich Heroin verkaufe
Woher kommt die Ware?
Wie kommen Sie dazu?
Ich rufe sie an,
und wir vereinbaren die Übergabe.
Wenn Sie anrufen,
sprechen Sie da französisch?
Ich rufe nicht an,
ich schicke eine SMS.
Sie haben die Nummer
bestimmt gespeichert.
Die geben Sie mir nun netterweise!
Dahin gehe ich normalerweise
für den Eigengebrauch.
Wie oft?
Jede Woche.
Einmal pro Woche?
Ein guter Rhythmus.
Sie weigern sich nicht,
mir die Nummer zu geben.
Nein. Sie würden mich
ja sowieso dazu zwingen.
Wieder sind die Fahnder unterwegs.
Diesmal geht es zu einem Informanten
Viel ist den Polizisten
darüber nicht zu entlocken.
Wir haben einen Hinweis bekommen,
dass ein Albaner
in einem öffentlichen Park
5-g-Heroin-Päckchen verkauft.
Wir versuchen,
ihn in flagranti zu erwischen.
Eine Nummer, ein Hinweis. Und schon
haben sie den Dealer im Visier.
Er wurde am Vorabend observiert.
Der dort?
Ich denke, ja.
Er ist es!
Lass mich raus!
Ich schnappe mir den Kerl.
Er hatte eine Kapuze auf?
Auf der Polizeistation müssen die
Kunden in einer Gegenüberstellung
ihre Lieferanten identifizieren.
Je mehr Kunden und Stoff,
desto mehr Gefängnis
bekommt der Dealer aufgebrummt.
Wir setzen ihm seine Mütze auf.
Und einen grauen Rucksack.
Ja, das ist er.
Wir haben ihn. Mit Mütze, ohne
Mütze, das macht einen Unterschied.
Auf dem Drogendezernat
herrscht Hochbetrieb.
Während von einem Dealer
Fingerabdrücke abgenommen werden,
identifiziert ein Fahnder
dessen Klienten.
In einem anderen Büro
wird Heroin inspiziert,
das einem Marokkaner
abgenommen wurde.
Das ist sehr kompakt.
Da drin sind 5 Säckchen.
Solche Dosen werden an Leute
verkauft, die kein Geld haben
und sich nicht 5 g aufs Mal
leisten können.
Sie kaufen diese Päckchen.
Abhängige, die sich
5-g-Päckchen leisten können,
machen daraus diese Kleinstdosen.
So haben sie ihre Investition
schnell einmal amortisiert.
Wie viele sind es? 80?
Genau.
Das hier sind Drogen,
die wir kürzlich während
einer Fahndung beschlagnahmt haben.
Es ist ungefähr 1 kg Heroin.
Und hier 1 kg Streckmittel.
Das dient dazu, die Ware
zu verdoppeln oder zu verdreifachen
Ich denke, das ist ein Tropfen,
verglichen mit der Menge Heroin
und Kokain,
die in der Schweiz gehandelt wird.
Aber so ein Coup
gelingt uns nicht jeden Tag.
Es ist ermutigend für uns,
wenn wir so viel
beschlagnahmen können.
Auch wenn es nur
die Spitze des Eisbergs ist,
wir tun etwas, und ein solches
Resultat ist doch interessant.
Eine Trophäe?
Ich denke, ein wenig schon. So eine
Ausbeute verzuckert eine Fahndung.
Dann gibt es noch
die synthetischen Drogen.
Für diese hochgiftigen Bonbons
sind in der Schweiz die Strafen
viel weniger hoch
als für Kokain oder Heroin.
Leicht zu bekommen, nicht teuer ...
Die Partydrogen
sind das Stiefkind der Fahnder.
Das Problem ist, dass unser
erster Fokus der Strassendeal ist.
Die Beschäftigung mit solchen Droge
ist eigentlich verlorene Zeit.
Viel Arbeit für praktisch nichts.
Aber ich denke,
diese Produkte werden zunehmen.
Die Preise werden sinken, die
Herstellungskosten sind sehr klein.
Die Gewinnmarge ist gross.
Die Drogen sind cool
und schmecken gut.
Und sie sind weit weg
vom Image des Abhängigen,
der an der Nadel hängt
und voller Blut ist.
Das ist eine saubere Sache,
und sie sehen wie Bonbons aus.
In den USA ist das Hauptproblem
der öffentlichen Gesundheit
die Droge Cristal Meth.
6-mal weniger teuer
und 10-mal wirksamer als Kokain.
Und auch viel zerstörerischer:
Ausfall der Zähne,
Zersetzung der Schleimhäute,
Degeneration des Gehirns.
Für mich ist Cristal Meth
die schlimmste Droge.
Da werden bald einmal
ein paar soziale Bomben hochgehen.
Die Schweiz ist für Dealer
ein Eldorado geworden,
weil die Sanktionen lächerlich sind
und kaum jemanden abschrecken.
Alle Fahnder sagen das Gleiche:
Wenn sie den Drogenhandel
nicht kontrollieren würden,
wäre es noch schlimmer.
Doch es braucht
eine grosse Portion Selbstlosigkeit,
um bei der Drogenpolizei zu arbeiten
Wir müssen diesen Kampf führen,
also tun wir es.
Und wir haben gute Gründe dafür.
Daran gibt es keine Zweifel.
Was mich motiviert, ist,
dass ich etwas
für die Gesellschaft tun kann.
Als Polizist braucht man
ein soziales Gewissen und ein Ideal
Das haben wir eigentlich alle.
Ich bin noch gleich motiviert
wie bei meiner ersten Patrouille.
Guten Tag.
Du übernimmst die Küche und das Bad
du den Schrank.
D'accord?
Ich denke, am Wichtigsten ist,
dass wir das Terrain nicht aufgeben
Wir müssen trotz der wenigen Erfolg
zeigen, dass die Polizei präsent is
und dass es ein Gesetz gibt.
Wer Drogen kauft und verkauft,
macht etwas Illegales.
Das ist das Wichtigste.
Wir dürfen unser Terrain
nicht aufgeben.
Das wäre der Anfang vom Ende.
Wir müssen unser Terrain verteidige
und unsere Leute motivieren,
dranzubleiben und möglichst andere
Wege der Drogenbekämpfung zu finden
die über die Repression hinausgehen
Die 2 Monate mit der Fahndern
haben gezeigt:
Sie können den Drogenhandel
eindämmen, mehr nicht.
Ihre Aufgabe ist denn auch
die Bekämpfung des Problems,
nicht dessen Ursachen.
Doch genau dort
braucht es neue Lösungen.
Das ist die grosse Herausforderung
für unsere Politik
und unsere Gesellschaft.